[Musique]
ce matin là cet atelier lecture pour les
cp de l'école henri wallon de trappes
pour faire la lecture la maîtresse
madame le moigne a la chance de pouvoir
suivre chacun des écoliers dans cette
classe bénéficiaires du dispositif cpd
doublé ils ne sont que onze élèves
la maîtresse peut ainsi répondre aux
besoins des enfants et s'adapter au
rythme de chacun si ce jour là il ya un
élève qui préférait qu'il y avait bien
acquis le son qu'on avait travaillé
aujourd'hui il a voulu directement pour
le texte en entier il a pu le faire un
élève qui est pas prêt à le faire
aujourd'hui et va le faire dans deux
jours et il réussira il sera en réussite
et
et c'est ce qu'on cherche je pense avec
le cp 100% réussite douze élèves par
classe maximum dans les zones dites
serait plus c'est aussi une nouvelle
relation qu'il faut bâtir entre enfants
et enseignants c'est aussi enfin
l'occasion pour tous de s'exprimer de
manière beaucoup plus importante
qu'auparavant et que chaque enfant un
ton parole dans la classe qui est
beaucoup plus long que ce qu'il a vu ce
qu'elle aurait eus en cp classique et ça
les fait progresser les élèves qui était
plus fragile plus timides ou plus en
difficulté progresse d'autant plus grâce
à cela de fonctionner à trappes depuis
la rentrée 2010 7,9 nouvelles classes
ont dû être créé pour accueillir maximum
douze élèves par enseignant
le dispositif sera élargie à la rentrée
prochaine à cinq nouvelles écoles de la
commune
les ce1 devrait aussi commencer à en
profiter un véritable casse tête
logistique pour la mairie au lieu
d'avoir comme à cette rentrée précédente
à
une classe individuelle de 12 élèves
on va être obligé de mettre deux
enseignants par classe en septembre
prochain deux écoles élémentaires de
plaisir profiteront aussi du cpd doublé
l'ensemble du dispositif ne sera qu
entièrement déployé dans les zones
d'éducation prioritaire qu'à la rentrée
2010 9